all right thank you
uh good morning everybody and welcome to
the uh
trafford covered 19 public engagement
board
um my name's george devlin i've agreed
to chair
in the absence of counsellor weston
um that's okay with everybody
[Music]
so do we have any apologies
i've not received any apologies apart
from fabio lafushi
okay thank you and of course i suppose
technically all the counsellors
on the meeting have also apologized or
thank you is there any declarations of
interest
the minutes of the previous sorry my
hand won't go up rebecca domain has also
sent apologies
all right thanks sarah
minutes of the last meeting which was
the 7th of april i think they've been
circulated
for people who are at the meeting
there's a an accurate record of
their meetings everybody happy with them
i'll take that as yes and i think
there's
no masses arising that are not on the
agenda today
so the fourth item in the agenda is an
update on the current
covert situation uh
moving on to the ten point plan mass
testing
okay so if i start with an
update on where we're up to at the
moment and then hand over to donna
on testing so um yeah the good news is
that our rates are dropping in trafford
um we are really seeing a significant
decrease which is fantastic news and i
think you know testament to
all the efforts that everybody has been
putting in and especially um
the efforts the people of trafford um
our highest rates are in our 17 to 29
year olds at the moment
and that group is um one where i think
we'd
um that we've seen higher rates in that
group in the past of course that group
almost ever been in that group isn't
eligible for vaccination yet
um and quite often won't be um
unwell with covid although we do see
long covert in some of those people
so i think the main message to our
younger population
is um you know it's do if you are
offered lateral flow tests do go for a
test
do remain symptom aware because we do
still have um covid's
um circulating so please do be aware of
the risks from covid to yourself and to
other people
and um you can either use the lateral
flow test
or if you're ill or if you're feeling
unwell do go for a pcr test and we'd
really strongly
strongly encourage people to do that um
i think this is fantastic i'm sure
everybody you know not only have we had
well not today so much sunshine but
you know there's better weather coupled
with the reopening of hospitality i
think it's
been a real a real boost for lots of
people
it's just been fantastic and
particularly for that younger population
who have borne so much of the brunt
of covid in terms of the impact on their
lives
and we know the unemployment rates and
so on in that group are
higher than for other groups of the
population so i think the main message
is
my message to that group is they have
been doing an amazing job they have been
fantastic they have been so responsible
all the way through i just cannot cannot
praise
that younger that you know our younger
working adults enough for everything
they've done
um just now please for them to continue
to be careful to stay outside for all of
us to
continue to be careful to stay outside
wherever we can
and for people working in the
hospitality industry
you know think about whether you it's
it's a hard one to say
um think about taking those lateral flow
tests and um
because people don't often maybe are
worried about having to self-isolate
again but
it's better to be safe than sorry and
please do take those lateral flow tests
there are plenty of sites where you can
pick them up
and let's try and make sure that this
reopening stays
and our road stays going smoothly and
our road map
is is working um we are giving advice
um with organizations reopening um i
suppose the other messages
it's really worth reviewing of
everybody's risk assessment so if you're
involved in a business that's reopening
if you're going back into the workplace
have a look around make sure that it
really is feeling covered secure to you
um have a talk with your manager if
you're the manager if you're the
business owner
review your business um those covered
security arrangements
because since lots of places haven't
been open really for
quite a few months and there's a lot of
difference now in the office we have
both around testing the promotion of
vaccination
but just making sure that the general
code security measures are in place
so that we can keep infection rates in
the workplace down because we are still
seeing um workplaces with it with
outbreaks
and we really don't want to see any more
workplace transmission
so really have a have a look at the
guidance
and review those were those risk
assessments before reopening
and um uh vaccination
people will talk about the vaccination
i'm just going to say we're making an
amazing progress to ccg
the gps have done a fantastic job on the
pharmacies
um there's some new we're hoping that
the
vaccination program will be expanding
quickly into the
um younger age groups and i'm sure sarah
and other ccg reps will be able to talk
more about that
um ramadan is obviously ramadan at the
moment
um and again we've we we've been working
very closely with the mosques
about making sure that people um know to
celebrate iftar
safely and not in groups and we're just
looking at
how we um how we support everybody with
making sure eid
is celebrated as safely as possible but
um you know this is obviously a very
special time for muslims
and we um we've been so impressed by the
work that the mosques and
people have been doing to make sure that
everybody's safe
um i think that is all i want to talk
about
today okay thanks eleanor for the
update and and the the report that
obviously everybody's seen previously
so thanks a lot is there any questions
or anything anybody would like
clarification
no okay
thank you uh we'll go on is it ten point
plan
uh mass testing that is that donna
yes thanks chair thank you for giving
the opportunity
um so we're doing about 20 000 tests a
week
um in trafford majority of those are the
lateral flow tests and
really pleased that um our frontline
workers
people working with vulnerable residents
and our schools
have really taken forward the lateral
flow test in a really systematic way
which is very very important lfts are
now
available for our community residents
throughout trafford
we have 58 pharmacists who are offering
lfts so people can collect
those and take them home with it so take
them home
so i think that's a really good coverage
again just a reminder that lfts
are for asymptomatic residents so people
who aren't displaying any symptoms um
and it's a really good test to take
um so that people aren't unknowingly
passing the virus on and we're just
doing a quick
appraisal of all our sites in trafford
to make sure that they're still
meeting needs of local residents
and how we can continue to promote those
um and uh obviously making sure
that the communications to those key
groups who maybe don't access them
um continue to go on um so at the moment
yeah i just feel as though the testing
opportunities are really wide throughout
trafford um
and we are seeing uh people taking them
up our positivity rate is one percent at
the moment that's quite
low uh chair uh it's the lowest it's
been for quite a long time so people are
taking the tests
and coming back with um with the results
that's really important for them
so i'll leave it there in case there's
any questions um i just wanted to
also update uh just going on from what
eleanor was saying about
services who are restarting
as a result of some of the releases in
lockdown
um been working closely with thrive
george
and we've now got a risk assessment for
any
community centres who want to set up
their sites
and that includes a building risk
assessment because obviously some of the
buildings have been closed so we just
need to check that the fire safety is
still in place
all the legionella checks and all those
really important health and safety
checks are in place
and some revised assessments for new
staff
because some of them will be opening
with new staff and many will be opening
with new volunteers
so making sure that all the volunteers
are trained and know exactly how to um
progress with making their environment
covered secure
and then the individual risk assessments
because some community centers might be
opening certain classes that they
haven't opened before
so we've just got to make sure those
risk assessments are in place
um i meet with the bcse every two weeks
and they find that really information
really helpful
in terms of planning and thinking things
through the future
thanks for that donna that's really
helpful
any questions from anybody
no okay so we're moving on to
contact tracing and outbreak management
um so just a very brief update from
contact tracing and the outbreak control
hub as we're now called
um we don't want to use the keyword but
it has been quite calm over the last
couple of weeks which has allowed us to
kind of
review some of our processes and
practice which has been really useful
um from the level two so if we start
through the
the national system level threes are the
individuals who get the contact from nhs
test and trace at a national level
first there's a new system in place now
so people are all asked if they need
any support to self-isolate
and are given a list of possible options
around support
if they do um report that they do need
support to self-isolate
then it's flagged on our system and
every day we get a daily feed of
our local residents who've requested
additional support so we've now got a
process in place locally
where we draw off the data in the
outbreak hub and share it with unbuckles
team who then contact the people
directly
and have a conversation about the level
of need so that's really
interesting and really important uh
numbers have been low coming through but
i think that just reflects our um
prevalence at the moment anyway instance
of uh of course anyway
so that's at the national level coming
through to the local
for those people who um cases again who
haven't been able to be contacted by the
national team they come through to us
within 24 hours
to our team in trafford we've had very
very small numbers of those as well but
again
where we do have um a responsibility to
contact them we are contacting about 70
of those at the moment so numbers
although incredibly small
our success is is looking good in terms
of our level ones which are
outbreaks or more complex settings again
um
we've had the easter holidays we're
coming out of lockdown so it has been
reasonably
um calm we've had one outbreak in the
school in north the borough which is uh
closed yesterday we have a new business
that we're working with around
a cluster of cases with them as well um
but in general it is pretty you know
calm and stable
what i just wanted to share with pebb
actually is an example of the strengths
of locality contact racing
so you'll know that a lot of the initial
contact tracing is done at a national
level
and we pick up the complex complex kind
of settings
and population settings so we've dealt
with over the last
six weeks one business four schools and
a care home that have all had
cases and when we've worked as a team
and looked at these
actually we've been able to demonstrate
that the cases from the businesses
all had children who went to four
different schools which had an outbreak
and had a family member who worked
in a care home as well so we were able
to see that these weren't actually
um six different outbreaks these were
all linked by
potentially two individuals who worked
together and had a coffee break together
so it really does demonstrate the
strength of that local intelligence and
that local knowledge
being able to draw the information
together so i just thought it was a
really
um good example to share with pebb
really about the benefits of local
knowledge and local intelligence so
that's our update from contact tracing
thank you
thanks helen i think that example's
really good because it makes it real
you know in terms of the local
connections and just how easy it is for
things to spread thank you
is there any questions for helen anybody
any no
okay thank you thanks helen um it's mass
vaccination
sorry would that be you yes it's me
today chair in the absence of rebecca so
i'm going to
take it um so just in terms of headlines
really for everybody
and obviously the mass vaccination is so
many different organizations and people
are involved in this so it's not one
particular sector or one particular
organization but
everyone's been working really really
hard so in terms of trafford
we're now at close to 50 of the
population having had their first
and second vaccination um so that's
really good news for us i think as as a
as a trafford as a borough and in those
top nine
cohorts those top nine groups that we've
been talking about for the past few
months
we're now at around 88 of those groups
have been vaccinated
um so again that's really good news in
terms of those people
who are most at need in terms of that
obviously there has been a lot in social
media about um
the az vaccine and there has been some
concern shown but we've been trying to
actually talk to people about that
discuss it with people in terms of
clinical risk which is
um in terms of what concerns we're about
and at the moment the only alternative
if people wanted that
to a z would be moderna that's offered
at the etihad
and so we have been talking to people
who have had any concerns and talking
them through all of that
we haven't had any um first dose
delivery this month but we will be
getting it from monday
so we're online now to go with our
delivery for first dose from monday as
well which again is really really good
news um
in terms of that expectation and then we
can start to
look at first doses for that wider
cohort of groups
um between 10 and 12 cohorts 10 and 12
so those adults
below the age of 50. um what data is
telling us across the rest of the north
west and i think what uh ellen has said
as well in her briefing is that
we aren't seeing really hesitancy in
that group people are wanting to be
vaccinated
and they're wanting to come forward so
we are thinking that that will also
happen as we
um go forward into those cohorts we have
two networks that won't be offering the
vaccination for those cohorts
out of the networks that we have and
there's lots of reasons for that
um obviously general practice is now
stepping up its other services as well
we're going back up to um for business
in terms of that
um staff capacity and there's quite a
lot you know people have been working
hard over many many months um around the
clock so there's a bit of
fatigue in there as well but the
networks that aren't offering to those
cohorts we will be offering it through
our pharmacies
so there will be coverage and it will be
coverage to our pharmacies so we will be
covered in terms of all of that
um for the next cohorts as we go forward
um
i think that's it sure really in terms
of the headlines i suppose the summary
is
we're on track people both those who are
being vaccinated and those who are
wanting to be vaccinated
um we're all sorted together in it and
we're on target now in terms of looking
at those other
cohorts as well over the next few weeks
thank you chair
thanks sarah through the good news
any questions anybody got anything that
they would like to ask
no okay thank you the next uh
item in the plan is community engagement
character and you picking that up yeah
and the first update i was going to give
is just around team personnel
and so we were recruiting for four uh
neighborhood engagement officers
they're all now in place and already uh
hard at work on various initiatives
uh so that's shazia awan siobhan foley
paris aguerovac and branson reeves and
so our team's now up to 10 members
and we're fully staffed so cracking on
our projects
uh an update of what we've delivered
over the past couple of weeks
um voice of bme the community group that
we commission
are still working closely with practices
in the north and
to contact people around boosting
vaccine confidence
and so far over 70 people who've
previously turned down the vaccine have
booked on
following those conversations which is
great we're also seeing more generally
in the north
a lot of increased vaccine confidence so
30 of people um in that primary care
network
who previously declined the vaccination
have now been vaccinated
which is really great and shows the
effectiveness of a lot of combined
initiatives and also a lot of work in
that community
by that community so that's fantastic
another stream that we're looking at at
the moment is vaccination in trafford's
homeless residents so we're linkedin
with services that support homeless
people
we've identified 57 people in trafford
and we're currently conducting community
engagement with them
around if they've been offered the
vaccine already
and what an offer that would suit them
might look like so things like mobile
units
so we're going out this week to talk to
residents and staff
of various services and we've already
got
on the 26th of april at one vaccination
clinic at one of those sites so that's
progressing
and there's been work on our
volunteering strategy so we've received
approval last week for increased funding
and investment
in volunteering that'll be a co-designed
approach using
our local community hubs and various
local community partners like the
traffic collective and thrive
and so we'll be delivering that as a
year pilot it'll also
include a community grant and for
community projects
working with people who are most at risk
from covid
and so that will increase uh
sustainability in the sector
and also delivery of social value
improved well-being for residents so
we're really excited about that
and how we um look at that and monitor
the benefits ongoing
uh another team update following
interviews on the 13th of april we're in
the process of appointing a volunteering
officer
and so that links to the item i just
mentioned on volunteering strategy
that particular role will be advancing
public sector volunteering
uh including the covered vaccination
clinics and testing sites
uh but also linking in with that bigger
model
um in terms of we've got plans coming
soon
uh we're gonna be soft launching the
community champions program this month
and looking at recruiting champions
within existing networks
uh so that's places again like the
community pubs thrive and the traffic
community collective
and we're gonna tell you a lot more
about that work soon
ahead of the larger public launch
uh we're doing work with muslim
community engagement
and there's a meeting of musk leaders
wednesday the 21st
they were linked in with the gmp are
hosting
uh they're going to use that for
introductions to the mosque leaders
uh discussing covert guidance ahead of
you
and also getting their thoughts on
putting on a vaccination setting after
you read prayers on the 11th or 12th of
may
and we're also supporting messaging
around an upcoming clinic
at limelight on the 22nd of april but
lots of updates there
yeah i'll also give a bit more detail on
a project we delivered last week on door
knocking in the north
and so our community engagement officers
went out and about to talk to residents
about how they were feeling
and any concerns they might have had as
things started to open up again
we focused on old trafford where we
carried out community impact assessments
and four streets
knocking on 73 doors the team were
working in pairs collecting information
and gathering consent via verbal
discussions with people at a safe
distance
we're using a model of a warm and open
approach to find out how people have
been during covert
what's their experience been like a
vaccination uh
tracy you're not on mute
sorry um what they'd like to see happen
from the council on public health next
in the fight against coverts and what
challenges they've faced across the
pandemic
um residents who expressed an interest
in finding out more about vaccination
and have also had their details passed
on with their consent
to the voice of vma the community group
i mentioned earlier
who have been doing those conversations
around increasing vaccine confidence
and uncovering and hesitancy with people
many people said they were feeling fine
initially but as we spoke to them they
opened up more about some of their
concerns
such as lost education the environment
and
more general points around covert and
and we're gonna disseminate our findings
um and create an action plan around them
with the various relevant teams
and and it will also help us um sort of
finalize our model going forward
but it was really useful work and we had
some very practical outcomes around
directing people to food banks mental
health support
and other support in the community so
that was very positive
i think that's it for me for an update
it's quite a lot covered there um the
only other thing to mention
is that soon um we're linked in with the
d orbit campaign across manchester
uh so we're working with community
figures and our communications team
to create some really localized
messaging
from people who've been vaccinated uh
supportive messaging around why you
should get the vaccination
thanks for that update catherine uh i
can't
come in there i just want to make a
comment really
uh you know normally from the community
side we are quite
keen to criticize the authorities but i
think in this case
it is a good uh good job
to engage these community engagement
officers
they have done an excellent job and i
think the this is the way forward
to link in to engage those people who
are with the communities
and people can have confidence in them i
think this is well
job well done and continue to do so
thank you so much
okay thanks for that feedback can
anybody else
i think i'd just like to add um to what
khan said i think
the the lessons that we're learning
through the work of
well through everybody's work but the
whole
approach to community engagement and
community involvement is going to be so
valuable for us as we're moving forward
out of uh covert but also just into the
recovery phase
and you know developing future services
so thanks to everybody for
the work that you've been doing and
eleanor i just want to add my
thanks to the team as well because it
has been a fantastic piece of work and
it is really making a difference when
you start looking you know
hearing what people are actually finding
compared to what we think they might
might be feeling and so on uh the the
increase in
information uptake has been absolutely
amazing through that work
um but it is that wider the wider um
understanding of what it's been like in
in different communities
is absolutely invaluable for us
designing our services going forward
we're really lucky because we've
actually been given um central
government funding for a lot of this so
we're able to
use that money to do this very specific
piece of work so
it is a fantastic um a fantastic way
forward
okay thanks elena
[Music]
there's no other questions comments we
move on to
community enforcement i think is that
you nikki
[Music]
i know sorry i'm a community engagement
um
okay is there anybody
i don't know whether nick can talk a
little bit about what the police have
been seeing
but my general understanding is that
compliance and so on has been
quite good um since the relaxation of
the
lockdown um i'm sure nick will have a
better perspective from the police
side hello chair it's nick young here
from uh greater manchester's police
i'm attending on behalf of our slt
there's been a huge amount of engagement
with the partnership as well so key
stakeholders around the table have all
been out over this last week
i would describe it very much like a
european style and it's been very very
good and the public public have been
absolutely fantastic
in terms of going out and re-engaging
the businesses have been on side and
have worked with the police and local
authorities
and overall it's been a really positive
experience
over the past week since the reopening
of licensed premises and certain
businesses across trafford so
it's really a big congratulations to
everybody and congratulations to the
public
for sticking to those rules we've
continuing to
have a presence on the streets this week
and running into the second weekend
and that again will be a joint
partnership approach between the police
and local authority which has been a
huge success
and uh yeah we just put that message out
and sort of
echo what eleanor rose said in terms of
congratulating people for sticking to
the rules and guidelines
okay thanks for that nick
so the next item is just any feedback
and any update on any other activity
that's been taking place in the past
couple of weeks
from any board members
okay is there any other business
i think we've got certainly got one item
around the next the date of the next
meeting
the next meeting should have been or was
planned for the
5th of may which is the day before the
elections
and the uh the council
committee meeting team are
pretty busy in terms of organizing
the elections and the current uh so i
think the suggestion is that we
cancel the next meeting unless there's
any
major changes that take place in the
next weeks in which case obviously we'll
reconvene
so the next meeting would be the 19th of
may
sorry yes the next one uh would be
the 19th of may okay
so if everybody um adjusts the calendars
for uh yeah
so i think if if we if we start seeing a
dramatic change in data or
um we need to do something we'll we'll
reconvene the meeting for the sixth but
otherwise
um yeah fifth rather but otherwise yes
the 19th
otherwise it'll be 19. yeah okay thanks
everybody
um i suppose the final thing is just
what's been really really good just
every part of the feedback today has all
been positive so
you know in a number of ways not just in
terms of um
the results but just in terms of the way
everybody's working together how there's
a real
system based approach how we're really
engaging in the community
and again i think as i said before we've
got so much to learn and so
many opportunities to kind of take
things forward in that way so
thanks to everybody and i suppose the
other part is that we just need to keep
it up
so enjoy the rest of the day
and uh we'll see everybody back in the
19th of may
thank you thank you very much bye hi
thank you